[Music]
foreign
on October 26th last year Elon Musk
walked into the Twitter offices carrying
a kitchen sink it was an appropriate end
to a training few months for everyone
who had followed the twists and turns of
his 44 billion dollar takeover of
Twitter No One initially expected that
musk would make a bid to take the
company private
the billionaire founder of Tesla
disclosed a stake in the social media
platform in early April becoming its
biggest shareholder
ten days later he offered to buy Twitter
for 54.20 per share most of the world
was still in the post-pandemic boom
where money was cheap Banks including
Morgan Stanley and Barclays offered to
land almost 13 billion dollars the
transaction and musk posted his tester
shares as collateral but shortly after
musk made his bed and refused to do due
diligence in order to get the deal over
the line he tried to walk back on the
watertight merger agreement it became a
captivating will he won't he Saga that
solidified his reputation as a Mercurial
billionaire whose defining
characteristic is unpredictability
the fight was set to end up in Delaware
where a judge would decide whether musk
had to buy the company
but just weeks before Twitter and musk
were said to come to her head they drew
up a settlement
the repercussions of that deal have been
widely felt
musk has removed more than two-thirds of
Twitter's employees and the banks that
helped finance the transaction are
sitting on billions of dollars of debt
they are unable to upload to investors
part of the reason is that markets have
taken a turn for the worse but investors
are also unwilling to deal with musk's
eccentricities
musk has promised to turn Twitter into a
more efficient and open tool for sharing
information or trying to keep wary
advertisers on the platform so he can
service the enormous amount of debt
weighing the company down
what is clear is that musk has become
perhaps the most powerful figure in the
media industry and in control of a
platform that is used daily by some of
the world's most influential figures
that that's again
[Music]